What's up, it's your boy, Pewdiepie!
Oh, it's another gameplay video. Oh, how about that
Pewdiepie never plays games!
shhhhhh shut the f**k u--
I play games all the time, all the time.
Have you opened your eyes, okay? I play games. I'm a gamer okay?
I'm the best gamer in the world. You know why?
Because I have the most amount of subscribers, yes, that's how it works.
More subscribers, better gaming skills
get on it, it's not that hard
Last episode,  I decided to draw a bunch of memes
and it upsets some website that I never heard about
saying that I am now leaning into my new far-right following
because drawing memes
is a political statement everyone , everyone knows that
Everyone knows that! You can't draw funny pictures
No no no no no that's a political statement, he's making there with that
The world is so f*****g stupid
What happened?
What happened to everyone?
It even went viral on the Tumblr,
And I was like, "Why?" That doesn't make any sense
and I found the source
the source is
Wil Wheaton
he reblogged it
And I know it's him
*laughs* because he BLOCKED ME
"Oh pewdiepie drew, he drew the pepe meme,
I don't like it man!"
BLOCK!
I get it, I don't like cartoon frogs that much either.
I have a toad. It's a s****y pet
I actually you know what it's justified
To avoid any form of controversy, because that would just be the worst thing ever
I am going to draw, this time ---other people
as requested by you bros
now, okay what should I draw, "draw my will to live" haha
Well, that should be a blank canvas
*laugh at his own joke
All right, who should I draw, can I get an actual suggestion?
okay I can't see anything so I'm just going to draw Will Wheaton
just gonna draw--
his chubby little face
Ahhh come on!
No one's bought it yet?
This game just piss me off, man
I don't get it, man
What am I doing wrong? What am I doing wrong in life?
I just want Well Weton (Will Wheaton) to love me
Does he not know about my wahmen respecting?
*giggles
Great. I just drew---
Great, alright well there he is
*laughs
there's nothing funny--
well let's see how it goes, let see, okay, who should we draw next
Jake Paul, everybody
It's everyday bro
Oh shit
"Monsieur, this tingles my facial hair!"
okay, well--
Will Wheaton sold quick, uhh I guess
here you go, take it
He sold for nothing?!!
AHHAAHAHAA
I didn't look at the price! What the f**k!
OOHHhh nooo, fam
ohhh no, hell, no man. God d**n it.
Why does no one want Nick Cromptooon??
Hahahahah, it's cute!
ahh shit, we gotta pay the bills, okay let's finish him
There we go. It's beautiful.
I'll call this one "
we came to
we came to a mutual
we came to a mutual agreement"
Done, it's perfect.
It's my perfect art
F**k we don't have a lot of money left
where's --- "This fella has no energy--"
Well,
you didn't watch hIS VIDEOOOOOOS
alright who shold we draw next?
well I guess it's Markiplier's turn, huh?
let's do his uhhh Darkiplier, as its called
Always drawing teeth makes for great details.
Look at that, looks so much better now. Yes
BEAUTIFUUUUUL
he's BEAUTIFUUUUUUL
I can't be bothered to finish this garbage, okay there we go
f*****g hell
"fanfiction crap"
Can we draw something decent now? Something more interesting, Jesus Christ
Pickle Rick it is, fam
finally a decent suggestion
"fanfiction crap was sold"
great
[intense music]
it's per--- hahah
It's kinda cute. You know what? I'll take it
It's a f**k it alright there it is, f**k take it, just---
"picklerick"
there we go
[disgusting burp]
"Draw Min YoonGi from BTS"
okay sure sure fam. I got you
I'm gonna draw the best goddamn fan art you've ever fucking seen baby
Can I uhh-- just the Nick Crompton one or is it just there forever?
Okay, I guess they don't like
They don't like Pickle Ricky there okay. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm so sorry
Now the thing is if this fan art doesn't come out perfect
I'm going to end my life
Life would not be worth living anymore
Remember this Felix, he has to be absolutely stunning
My whole life depends on this fan art,  I'm not joking
It's beautiful. Let me just finish off with a little---
*v is his band-mate's stage name*
Perfect. It's perfect there it is
there it is, fam
there you go
"MIN YOONH"
there you go, this one better make me rich
'fuck's with all these shitty suggestions man
okay, we can draw some fupa fan art
everyone's always doing that
I think I'll draw this version
let's begin
I'm actually enjoying this, this is really fun to draw
" The choice of color is a bit too radical."
The choice of letting you live is a bit too radical okay? How about that?
not afraid to spit the truth, fam
Look at that boi !
Now that's art man
That's fucking art. If that's not art, I don't know what I don't even want to know what art is
🎵I want to know what art is🎵
Is there any way we can make him a lil cuter, I feel like---
oh there it is
there it is
There it IIIISSSSSS
YEEEEEEESSS
I feel like the--- the art is trying to seduce me
I like it, keep going
OOh yes, it's getting steamy in here
ohhhh yees
*laughs* I actually like it
Yes ! It's beautiful
I'll call it "FUPA"
I can't believe Nick Crompton hasn't sold yet
What the fuck
"This fella has no energy--" fuck off! Yall fuck off
you don't know shit
okay who should we draw ne---
"Draw Dolan Dark"
Okay, all right Fam
I will I shall
I shall draw him, with all my might and power, you better watch your fucking duckling
You better meme out of this you fucking-- I dunno why I'm so mean to you now, all the sudden, you're beautiful
I think it's obvious that I clearly stopped trying at some point
Here and this one, it just really doesn't look like a duck
alright, "MEMES", there you go
There you go, fuck off
Hey, Ethan's sold, everybody
man, Fupa sold for a lot, Jesus
wew should we do another Nick Crompton
He looks so sad, I really want to capture his sad soul in this one.
I feel like-- what am I doing? What's happening?
Oh my God, an art critic
*gasp* The critic! He's judging my BTS fanart!
I see
What does he say?
That's it??
That's fucking it??
Fuck off
*gasp*
MASTERCRAFT!!
HE CALLED IT A MASTERCRAFT!
MIN YOONH
MIIN YOOOONH A MASTERCRAFT
I knew I had the talent
I knew I had the talent, man
Alright, the next act, okay, what is that
I mean, I'll take it
"You have unlocked a new tool"
Maybe I can actually draw properly now instead of these shitty ones
What do I do, okay, I draw, okay
Cute, so what is this?
Oh it's much more defined
okay I got it
Nice
Ahhhh
Yes
aaaah that every stroke makes me want to stroke a
Nick,
🎵Nick Crompton is the most beautiful man. I've seen,
I wanna run away, with you🎵
🎵Nick Crompton, just me and you 🎵
Nick Crompton I just notice your collar's not---
It's not popping. It's not popping in this picture I just really--
just want to point that out, point that out to everyone
[earrape version of Nick rapping]
His eyes
They scream
save me
"Save me!"
tasukete (save me)
tasukete (help me)
tasukete, pewdie-sama!
tasukete pewdie-sama
this collar
I'm gonna make poppin for you Nick
That's right. Look at it.
It's popping
That was beautiful. That was goddamn beautiful
"tasukete pewdiesama"
Alright I'll let you guys guess which one this is
It's My nama Jeff Channing Tatum, everyone
I really captured it
I really think I captured it quite perfectly I gotta say I'm-
very proud of myself
feel like the eyes could probably use a little more work
fuck it, there it is
"ma neme
e jeeffffeeeEEEE"
That's all for me for now, boys and girls
Mainly girls of course
Thank you for watching me draw--
this beautiful art
and I'll see you, in the next one
Stay sistering--my fisters